all right so another day another
shooting in America this happened at
Chapel Hill this morning apparently
three Muslim Americans were shot by a
man a white man who apparently was
either an atheist or an anti theist
depending on what you see on his
Facebook page it is awful regardless of
the religion of the people that got shot
regardless of the beliefs or lack
thereof of the people who did the
shooting we are Americans we should not
be shooting each other you can talk
about gun control and all the other
socio-economic things that cause people
to do stupid things it sounded like
there was a fight in the parking lot
some people are saying this had nothing
to do with religion that sounds a little
suspect to me if you shoot three people
who are knowingly Muslims I don't know
what the truth is I would be equally
outraged
whichever configuration you want if a
Muslim shot three atheists I would be
upset if a Jew shot three Hindus I'd be
upset if I can do every every which way
but so what I want to talk about and we
don't know a lot of the specifics this
just happened so I don't want to
speculate as everyone on TV does all the
time right we're not going to speculate
about this now here's some speculation
so I don't want to speculate on what
this guy's beliefs were what the motives
were I'm sure hopefully that will come
out and it's and the media is picking up
on this now but what I want to talk
about is the immediate backlash that I
was seeing subtly on atheists online I
kept seeing all these people say you see
we have these new atheists and what
they're really they're talking about sam
harris and they're talking about richard
dawkins and they're talking about bill
maher and they're saying see these
atheists they've been ginning up hate
and now look what happened an atheist
went ahead and shot some people there's
a there's just no reason to make that
that jump in logic we don't know that
this has literally anything to do with
this guy being atheist number one number
two there's no doctrine in atheism they
don't have a book by the way there's no
book that they would turn to and go oh I
should shoot a non-believer guess what
I'm the non-believer that's how it works
and atheism so I think it's really
really dangerous for us and especially
people on the left to turn against the
atheist generally speaking and look no
group no group of people and no one
person is perfect but generally speaking
atheists are for science and rationality
and
reality right and not are not drawn by
bigger things so anyway let's take a
moment before everyone goes crazy and
starts using this for political purposes
and don't turn on the freakin atheist as
a community because that's not the
problem here